this is the big lead you got  doesn't look like he's gonna keep the  lights on much less buy me a lobster  dinner  what about the doliak bounty i hear he's  still out by the belt i told you running  after ship jackers is a wild goose chase  this guy's right in front of us last  seen in new tijuana  tj no no tj what now  do you know what i got the last time i  was on tj  herpes  stabbed you know what i was doing buying  a churro there's got to be something  better jed come on my daughter's turning  eight  and i can't afford to buy her a present  because of you  i can afford a goddamn walking sally  doll which is apparently all the goddamn  rage in little girls toys because of you  now this is my ship and as long as  you're on it  we're gonna go after the bounties i say  we go after  do you feel better  yeah  [Music]